most bosses they don't want their
employees to be rich they want them to
keep them poor this week i'm helping my
employee get rich in five days from
scratch yo let's do this hi thanks for
taking the call it's emilia why would i
give you one of my properties i just
didn't know what to say i was mixing up
my words i think it was awful i think it
was awful have you even got a company
set one up about a few weeks ago
facebook and instagram are down it's not
about getting a deal sometimes what it
is yeah it's a good lead whether i can
actually secure it is uh we've got more
to do tomorrow
more to do if we're in london you need
to get planning permission
to rent a property out on short stay lex
this is my favorite
you're gonna be a homeowner
excuse me do you know where the estate
agents are what's the worst that can
happen the worst cameras you get
rejected yeah it's in better condition
than i was thinking in my head
but we've got our viewing from 20
minutes
95
mortgage what the heck let's just offer
on it
i'm just hoping that i get paid tonight
oh
if they don't say yes
i don't know what i'm gonna do
like i literally don't know what i'm
gonna do facebook is down
i can't
it literally what am i gonna do
i need to get something sorted tonight
so we need to get him a lease option
agreement contract and a renter in
contract
now
[Music]
you're a very pushy landlord no one's
gonna pay you four grand for a laugh oh
you see the house
[Music]
yo bear mom we're gonna be getting a
deal every day every single day brother
there's only 17 prophecies we'll have to
spend everything you've got on this
deposit yeah
it's because it's two you say speaking
too long i've never had um
an app
tell me the show
yeah it's like [ __ ] you're talking too
long
[Music]
to success yeah financial freedom
no i think i don't think i've put his
address in i think i've just put the
actual windsor castle in on stage
my bad i've got one minute oh my
goodness five minutes away